stephane going to be a country in which
he is welcome one which I think a lot of
people will have high regard for him as
a pontiff who was quite a different
style to some of his predecessors who's
somebody who's talked about protecting
the planet about climate change about
migration about four and somebody who
has I think helped to maybe soften some
of the harder edges of Catholic doctrine
at least in what you said if not in
terms of changes the doctrine itself you
are this country's first openly gay
prime minister how big a deal is this
for you personally what for me as as a
checkers prime minister really maybe my
role is to make sure that Pope Francis
is is welcome that the events happen and
we've made sure that health and safety
and security that all that works out as
we've planned but also an opportunity to
me to meet with him an opportunity for
me to speak to him as well and also to
what I hope will be the opening of a new
chapter in the relationship between
Ireland's the Irish state and the
Catholic Church but how do you reconcile
the teaching of that church on
homosexuality considered evil by the
Catholic Church with the fact that you
are a gay man and you are leading a
country that has voted for same-sex
marriage well first of all I welcome the
fact that Pope Francis has said that he
has raised that question who am I to
judge when it comes to these issues and
I think his statement in that regards
who would have come as words of great
encouragement to lesbians and gay men
and people are bisexual they're also
deeply Catholic but I'm very much
somebody who believes in a greater
separation of church and state and I
believe in freedom of religion and if
you believe in those things you have to
respect the fact that the Catholic
Church or the Christian churches at the
Muslim faith the Jewish faith other
faiths will have religious views that
you don't like but at the same time you
have to be willing to respect that
you have a very short meeting with the
pontiff on Saturday morning what will be
the most pressing issue for you
I think would be a couple of things it's
very short meeting only 10 minutes and I
don't want to skirt over lots of topics
just say that I raise them so I'm gonna
try to use the time as best I can and
the first is of course to welcome to
Ireland on behalf of the Irish people
half of the faithful in protect in
particular secondly to talk about my
wish that we can open a new chapter in
relations between Ireland the Irish
state and the Catholic Church one that
is more equal one that is more
respectful and one that is more modern
and also of course I will want to talk
about humans right human rights issues
and issues related to sex abuse and the
mistreatment of children and women by
the church as institutions often with
the collusion of the stage we should
bear in mind in the past tsuki were born
in nineteen seventy ninth year of the
last papal visit back then no one was
talking about the issue of the sexual
abuse of children by Catholic priests to
what extent can the Prime Minister of
any country put pressure on the Vatican
for full disclosure on that issue I
think we can and I think we have to
things are far from perfect in Ireland
when it comes to issues around child
protection but we have made a lot of
strides in the right direction in the
last couple of years we don't for
example have any statute of limitations
when it comes to prosecuting people who
are perpetrators of child sex abuse and
we've brought in mandatory reporting as
of last year and that's not the case in
other countries it's not the case with
every country anyway but I believe
whether it's the law of the land or not
it's good practice and she'll be applied
across the board by the church all over
the world and they had the power to do
that if they wish to do so things have
changed dramatically here in Ireland but
of course the church still does have
considerable influence in terms of
Education and hospitals do you envisage
that changing anytime soon I think it
will change I think it should change but
I'm also not not an extreme secularist
either
I think that's there is a role to play a
valuable role to play for religious
bodies of all sorts when it comes to
charitable provision when it comes to
welfare we know about some of the
wonderful organizations that are helping
us deal with the homelessness crisis and
there are a lot of people who want to be
able to send their kids to schools that
are faith-based and we need to find
space in our society for that you almost
mentioned in an off-the-cuff way not
secularist does that mean you've got a
personal faith yourself
I brought up as Catholic so I rarely
communion in my confirmation and but was
also brought up to open a mixed-race
mixed religion house my parents are
particularly just my mom's Catholic my
dad's Hindu so I was always aware that
there were other faiths and other belief
systems out there and III I'm not I
don't practice any religion at the
moment so I guess like a lot of people
in Ireland I'm I come from a Catholic
background but I'm still searching for
the truth